ciao a tutti e oggi andremo a fare una
challenge uci boreale contro cibo o
rimandare gli origami e devo farli con
gli origami trentina dei tripolini 3d
che potete trovare in edicola sono anche
profumati si possono creare un sacco di
cose serie di libri di e ci sono tre le
confezioni diverse in allegato magazine
ora facciamo vedere allora potete
trovare 2000 mix choc i meant tribù
litri di in edicola il sogno varie
bustine potete prendere le bustine da 25
triangolini 3d a solo 1 euro
ci sono tanti gli ultimi colori sono
tutte profumante robusti da 50
triangolini 3d a 199 vengono sempre un
allegato colmare tn marchese ci sono
anche le istruzioni per costruire
varicose sono questi origami pure ci
sono le scatoline a 2 euro e 99 in cui
potete trovare sempre 53 molini 3d di
due colori diversi sono profumati e ora
vi faccio vedere il marketing e in ogni
magazine
potete trovare le istruzioni per
costruire le varie cose soft classic
prua e gli special dei triangoli li
vedete ci sono qua fare le istruzioni
per costruire gli oggetti o cibo animali
sono stufo il carini e queste sono
alcune istituzioni ma se volete potete
costruire voi quello che volete pozzi
insomma dare spazio la fantasia questo
nuovo trend
momento quando ero piccola io c'era il
trend degli scopi 2 e adesso c'è il
trend degli origami e già provati
evitare io no mi piacciono le piccole
cose molto più bravo di me parli turno
avremo in una cloche avremo l'origami è
una grossa primo e cibo reale e
chiediamo a chi capitano di davis e mi
capita il cibo reale alla fine dovrete
votare quale loriga mix che vi è
piaciuto più di tutti quindi alla fine
il mio invito il sondaggio quale dovrete
votare me federica di credete impatta
famiglia allora prima un sito lo tieni a
lo scambio si può pure scambiare io non
mi fido di rotello
vediamo
a questo proposito appare tra l'altro
abbiamo anche messo degli origami
se vediamo se riuscite a vederli deco
qua come fare le banane origami 3 2 1
[Musica]
[Applauso]
in questo gioco vizio punto chi ha
alloggiato riga mix quindi siamo uno e
zero con allora dove ti sei triste
tenerlo scambiarlo non posso dire prima
di tutto quindi ora del sito io mi
offrirà come prima il campiello dico
scambio
[Musica]
per 20 30 quale mi avete mangia tutta
cordate che carino era uguale che non
mangia si aspetta perché lo posso
rendere nuovamente uguale ma vediamo
tutte poesia finirla ma la mia vita
tanto milanesi mentre disse 974
rimaniamo ancora definita ma va posto
anche il ricomporre il segmento vi
facciamo vedere come realizzare la
stessa insieme questi due fronti di
trento
[Musica]
siamo tutte il penultimo round allora lo
scambi allora l'altra volta ha ottenuto
forte questa volta uno scambio
vediamo se mi porta fortuna perché riti
e non sorridendo io credo sempre il pari
va bene si scambiano 32
[Musica]
io ho il caffè numero e vitale al capiti
di oliva sembrano uguali che carini
perché li potete realizzare dei colori
che volete ovviamente no è mio è mio me
lo mangio io credere
[Musica]
no non ci casca tuttavia era vi facciamo
vedere tutto della sua anima realizzare
il cup cakes di brodo di 32 euro
[Musica]
[Applauso]
allora siamo al quarto e ultimo round
stati molto grande crisi di ciascun
posti vede quindi un po lo abbiamo già
capito da un lunghissimo vero adesso
libro quello origami ma comunque che
potessi per ios è tenuto a cambiarlo
anzi no sì come già sappiamo cosa c'è
dentro era troppo grande e facciamo
carta forbice sa se vediamo è
interessante perché siamo già a 12
mi sono annotati su cosa si muovesse
sarà la battaglia decisiva per il round
decisivo
vediamo grazie ha incoraggiato perché
non ci stava
guardate e incredibile con gli origami
si può fare qualsiasi cosa
e questa la storica di seggi da gigante
perché praticamente qualsiasi tutorial
lo potete seguire è raddoppiare i pezzi
e farlo ancora più grande
e se volete poterle parlare che
centesimo noi abbiamo solo raddoppiato i
pezzi persona ed è uscito di doppio più
grande ma se volete si possono anche
triplicare quadruplicare farlo bene
e bellissimo davvero lo zero come ben si
può anche usare come portate evitare
stato bravissimo a realizzare queste ore
le facili da fare fino poi a me
piacciono tanto incastrare tutti questi
gli imperativi di triangolini di origami
si sono anche rilassanti da fare ed arti
seguire le istruzioni perché nelle
istruzioni ci sono tutti tutti i vari
incastri dover spiegato all'inizio su
come fare gli incastri dei triangoli
profumo tantissimo perché mi tripolino
profumato quindi questa tardiva rigliaco
libricino trovate lo schema su come
farlo però comunque potete cambiare
anche i colori io infatti qui sono
andato un po fantasia e in base ai
colori che avevo a disposizione o quelli
che mi piacevano di più ho fatto le
varie sfumature di verde anche marrane e
varie sfumature di giallo il marrone che
ti fanno del colera che volete possiamo
che fare un buon tempo
ma c'è un problema siamo 2 a 2
vuoi avere la corona via la paura di
cosa le replica timido rivincita al
versate un like borselli sita e ora vi
facciamo vedere il tutorial dell'ana
nostro zitto pronti 32
[Musica]
[Applauso]
allora nessun bacio quale l'origami che
vi è piaciuto più di tutti il cupcake la
lebbra è la fetta di anguria e il mare
una sola votate come quello che mi è
piaciuto di più a me quello che piace di
più è la nostra bellissima avrete kink
invece che mancava un passato col naso
basta però profumo benissimo a questo
profumo di nocciola cioccolato per
milioni allora lasciatemi pensare che se
volete vedere altre creazioni come gli
origami qui trovate in edicola nelle
varie bustine da 25 pezzi 50 pezzi o 50
pezzi sono generate creazione montate me
la presidenza granché sono super curiosi
a quattro casalinghe se puoi cliccare
per vedere i nostri altri video
applicate su quella che preferite